people think that cash is the safest  investment  but they are measuring that  in  the amount of money that they get  nominal returns and they say it doesn't  wiggle much  but think about it inflation is eight  and a half percent and they receive  virtually no interest rate in cash and  so there's an eight and a half percent  loss of buying power  as a result of inflation you have to  think in terms of buying power  not the number of dollars you have so  the worst thing  is to be in cash like i say cash is  trash  you start off with a  well-diversified balanced portfolio  because  diversification  can reduce your risk without reducing  your return